les images que vous voyez ici ce sont
celles d'une des plus grandes
simulations d'Univers Virtuels jamais
réalisées la simulation Millenium
les tâches de couleur représentent la
concentration de la matière aux
différents endroits de l'univers
et comme vous pouvez le constater cette
matière semble former des structures
bien particulières on observe comme une
toile cosmique constituée de filaments
dont la taille peut atteindre des
centaines de millions d'années-lumière
aux intersections de ces filaments des
zones où se concentrent la matière et
dans laquelle on trouve des grappes de
galaxies
et oui car nous observons ici l'univers
à une échelle absolument gigantesque
chaque minuscule point lumineux que vous
voyez ici ça n'est pas une étoile non il
s'agit d'une galaxie toute entière une
galaxie comme notre Voie Lactée
évidemment ceci n'est qu'une simulation
mais on a de très bonnes raisons de
penser que ce que vous avez vu là et
représentatif de la structure de notre
univers dans son ensemble alors
aujourd'hui voyons comment il est
possible de connaître et de simuler
l'univers à ses échelles gigantesques
[Musique]
commençons par un peu d'historique
pendant très longtemps on a pensé que
l'univers se limitait à ce qu'on voyait
au-dessus de nos têtes la nuit des
étoiles un peu partout et notamment
regroupés au sein de cette grande
traînée pâle dans le ciel nocturne qu'on
appelle la Voie lactée et puis rien de
plus
jusqu'au début du 20e siècle on ne
parlait pas de galaxies le concept
n'existait pas il a fallu attendre les
années 1920 pour que l'astronome Edwin
Hubble mesure la distance qui nous
sépare de ce qu'on appelait à l'époque
la nébuleuse d'Andromède et que l'on
réalise alors que celle-ci se trouvait
beaucoup beaucoup plus loin que tout ce
qu'on avait pu imaginer que cette
nébuleuse était une sorte de voie lactée
numéro 2 mais si tu es à plus de 2
millions d'années lumière de nous
et c'est ainsi qu'on a peu à peu
commencé à réaliser que l’univers tout
entier était rempli de ses paquets
d'étoiles qu'on a appelé des galaxies
aujourd'hui évidemment avec les
instruments modernes d'observation des
galaxies on en voit partout et on en
connaît un très grand nombre avec des
clichés comme celui-ci pris par le
télescope spatial Hubble on peut estimer
qu'il existerait des centaines de
milliards de galaxies dans l'Univers
observable
donc vu depuis la Terre il semble qu'il
y ait des galaxies un peu partout dans
le ciel mais est-ce que c'est vraiment
le cas comment sont-elles réparties dans
l'univers globalement si on pouvait
prendre du recul et les observer toutes
est-ce qu'il y a des coins à galaxies
qui en contiennent plus que d'autres
comme il y a des coins à champignons
dans les forêts ou au contraire est-ce
qu'elles sont réparties de façon
relativement homogène une hypothèse
naturelle ça serait de penser qu'elles
sont distribuées de façon aléatoire par
exemple 6 ou disques représentent une
portion de l'univers visible et que je
tire des points au hasard dedans pour
représenter les galaxies j'obtiens un
truc de ce genre il y en a un peu
partout évidemment par coïncidence on a
quelques endroits qui en contiennent un
peu plus mais dans l'ensemble c'est
assez homogène et ce serait plutôt
naturel de penser qu'à grande échelle la
répartition des galaxies dans l'Univers
ressemble un peu à ça
sauf que depuis quelques dizaines
d'années maintenant on sait qu'il n'en
est rien les galaxies sont en réalité
réparties d'une façon bien spécifique
dans l'espace pour s'en convaincre il
faut être capable de mesurer et de
représenter la position des galaxies
dans un volume suffisant et il faut
vraiment le faire en 3d on peut pas
juste regarder les galaxies dans le ciel
et en faire une simple carte il faut
qu'on ait une idée de la distance à
laquelle elle se situe de nous et
connaître cette distance c'est un peu
plus compliqué que juste faire une photo
mais il y a une solution on sait que les
galaxies les plus lointaines s'éloignent
le plus vite de nous à cause de
l'expansion de l'Univers et cela se
traduit dans leur couleur les galaxies
lointaines paraîtront plus rouges
donc en mesurant avec suffisamment de
précision leur spectre lumineux on peut
estimer leur vitesse d'éloignement et
donc leur distance à nous c'est ce qu'on
appelle la méthode du décalage vers le
rouge et c'est ce qui permet de
reconstituer leur position en 3D pour
mieux comprendre la répartition des
galaxies il nous faut donc appliquer
cette méthode sur un volume suffisant de
l'univers une des premières tentatives
de ce type a commencé dans les années 80
sous la direction des astronomes
Margaret Geller et John hochra on
appelle cela le relevé CFA2 pour
l'établir nos astronomes on mesurer la
position et la couleur de 18000 galaxies
situées dans une bande de ciel de
quelques degrés et comme on a à la fois
leur position dans le ciel et leur
distance et bien la région ainsi
couverte est un volume de forme un peu
conique
vous voyez ici une figure publiée en
1989 qui représente la position de
galaxies mesurée dans ce cône jusqu'à
des distances de près de 700 millions
d'années-lumière et comme vous pouvez le
constater la distribution de ces
galaxies est loin d'être uniforme elle
semble s'agglutiner dans certaines zones
et d'autres endroits au contraire sont
presque vides comme si les galaxies se
rassemblaient sur la surface de grosses
bulles et la grande structure allongée
qui traverse le champ d'observation ici
a été baptisé le grand mur alors
attention ne vous méprenez pas les
galaxies ne sont pas entassées les unes
sur les autres de façon qui bloquerait
le passage mais on a dans cette zone une
concentration anormalement élevée de
galaxies
ce mur de galaxies fait une taille de
plusieurs centaines de millions
d'années-lumière pour une épaisseur de
seulement 16 millions d'années-lumière
comme si toutes ces galaxies avaient
décidé de se rassembler dans cette fine
tranche de l'espace le relevé CFA2 a été
l'un des premiers à mettre en évidence
ce genre de structure mais il y a eu
depuis bien d'autres campagnes
d'observation qui ont permis d'établir
des relevés de position encore plus
importants jusqu'à des distances
toujours plus grandes par exemple le
relevé d'EDF établi entre 1997 et 2002
et dont vous pouvez voir ici une
représentation des résultats il
répertorie au total la position
d'environ 200 000 galaxies et à relever
des structures jusqu'à 2 milliards
d'années-lumière de distance
depuis les années 2000 c’est
l’expérience SDS pour slown Digital Sky
survêt qui a pris le relais et ce grâce
à un télescope spécialement dédié à cela
vous voyez ici une reconstitution en 3D
de la position de dizaines de milliers
de galaxies parmi plus d'un million qui
ont été mesurés et caractérisés par le
télescope SDSS
en 2003 la collaboration svss a
notamment annoncé la découverte de ce
qu'on appelle le grand mur de slown un
autre mur de galaxies qui lui serait 2 à
3 fois plus grand que le mur de CFA2
dont on a parlé toutes ces observations
nous peignent donc l'univers comme une
sorte de grande toile d'araignée
cosmique constituée de murs de galaxies
de filaments et entre lesquels se trouve
d'immense zone largement dépeuplées
d'ailleurs notre galaxie la Voie Lactée
se trouve elle-même sur un de ses
filaments baptisé le filament poisson
baleine du nom des constellations qu'il
faut viser dans le ciel pour l'observer
on voit donc avec tout cela qu’on semble
très loin d'une répartition homogène des
galaxies dans l'Univers ce qui semblait
pourtant une hypothèse raisonnable mais
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut
expliquer la formation de ces structures
étonnantes pourquoi une répartition si
particulière qu'est-ce qui explique la
taille de ces murs de ces filaments
et bien pour le comprendre il faut se
tourner vers le modèle du Big Bang pour
essayer de simuler l'évolution de
l'univers
[Musique]
commençons par la vue d'ensemble on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il y a 13,8 milliards
d'années l'univers était dans un état
très très dense et très très chaud et
qu'il s'est depuis dilaté et refroidit
une des confirmations expérimentales les
plus spectaculaires de ce scénario c'est
le rayonnement fossile il s'agit d'une
sorte de photographie de l'univers tel
qu'il était 380 000 ans après le Big
Bang à l'époque de la formation des
premiers atomes et cela se manifeste
aujourd'hui par un rayonnement
électromagnétique faible mais qu'on peut
observer dans toutes les directions du
ciel
ce rayonnement a une caractéristique
bien précise il correspond à celui qui
mettrait un corps ayant une température
de 2,73 Kelvin donc seulement 2,73
degrés au-dessus du zéro absolu et ce
qui est fascinant c'est que ce
rayonnement est extrêmement homogène
quel que soit la direction du ciel dans
laquelle on regarde il semble quasiment
identique 2,73 Kelvin cet uniformité
traduit qu'à l'époque où ce rayonnement
a été émis donc 380 000 ans après le Big
Bang la répartition de la matière
présente à l'époque devait elle aussi
être extrêmement homogène car oui à ce
moment là il n'y avait pas de planètes
pas d'étoiles pas de galaxies juste du
gaz un peu partout de l'hydrogène et un
peu d'hélium et si on en croit
l'uniformité du rayonnement fossile la
densité de ce gaz devait être quasiment
la même partout dans l'univers alors
mettons des chiffres sur cette idée
parce qu'on peut préciser ce quasiment
le rayonnement fossile a été découvert
dans les années 1960 et à l'époque il
paraissait complètement homogène et il a
fallu attendre plus de 30 ans pour
détecter les premières très légères
inhomogénéités de sa température plus
précisément on sait aujourd'hui que ce
rayonnement a une température de
2,728 Kelvin plus ou moins
0,002 Kelvin c'est ce que traduisent les
variations de couleurs qu'on voit sur
les cartes de ce genre 2,728 plus ou
moins 0,02 ça veut dire que ce
rayonnement fossile est homogène à 0,1%
prêt ça signifie qu'à l'époque où il a
été émis 380 000 ans après le Big Bang
il pouvait exister de très légères
variations de densité de matière dans
l'univers un peu plus par-ci un peu
moins par là mais qu'elle devait
certainement être du même ordre environ
0,1%
la densité du gaz était extrêmement
homogène avec juste d'un film
perturbations dans la répartition de la
matière comme des petites rides dont on
pense qu'elle trouve leur origine dans
les fluctuations quantiques de l'Univers
primordial
mais si à cette époque il y a 13,8
milliards d'années la répartition de la
matière dans l'univers était si homogène
comment se fait-il que ce soit plus le
cas maintenant on est aujourd'hui des
zones pleines de galaxies des murs des
filaments et à côté d'autres régions
quasiment vides et bien c'est parce que
la force de gravité a peu à peu accentué
les différences de densité et amplifier
les rides minuscules qui existaient à
l'époque pour donner ses grandes
structures qu'on observe aujourd'hui
alors voyons comment ça a pu se produire
imaginez que je prenne quelques objets
massifs que je disperse dans l'espace
bon disons des galaxies mais ça pourrait
être autre chose comme de simples nuages
de gaz
puisque la gravité est une force
attractive c'est masse vont s'attirer et
finir par se rapprocher les unes des
autres donc on a envie de penser que
toutes les galaxies de l'univers
devraient maintenant se retrouver
groupés dans un seul coin les unes sur
les autres sauf qu'il y a aussi
l'expansion de l'Univers qui dilate
toutes les distances et donc il va en
quelque sorte s'opposer en partie à
l'attraction alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe si on combine les deux phénomènes
expansion et attraction et bien c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut calculer on
prend un univers en expansion dont on
connaît l'évolution par la théorie du
Big Bang on balance dedans plein de
particules massives qui représentent par
exemple des galaxies ou des morceaux de
galaxies et on voit ce qui se passe pour
calculer l'attraction que ces galaxies
exercent les unes sur les autres pas
besoin de sortir l'artillerie lourde la
gravité de Newton fait largement
l'affaire on calcule les forces comme on
la prend au lycée mais on ajoute l'effet
de l'expansion de l'Univers et on a une
belle équation pour représenter
l'évolution de nos galaxies alors manque
de bol cette équation est impossible à
résoudre directement par le calcul
d'ailleurs même sans l'expansion de
l'Univers c'est un problème bien connu
qu'on appelle le problème à ncor si on a
juste deux corps qui s'attirent on sait
calculer exactement leur trajectoire à
partir de 3 c'est impossible et ça
devient chaotique et le mieux qu'on
puisse faire ce sont des simulations
numériques sur le papier le principe est
simple on part d'une distribution
initiale de galaxies et on va les faire
se déplacer petit à petit à chaque étape
de la simulation on calcule les forces
qui s'exerce sur chaque galaxie et on la
déplace un peu en fonction et on
recommence autant de fois que nécessaire
la seule difficulté c'est que chaque
galaxie subit en principe l’influence de
toutes les autres galaxies donc il faut
calculer toutes les forces qui
s'exercent entre toutes les galaxies si
on a n Galaxy dans notre simulation on a
en gros n² force à calculer à chaque
étape donc ça prend vite beaucoup de
temps les premières simulations de ce
genre ont été réalisées à la fin des
années 70 en prenant quelques milliers
de masse dans un volume représentant un
cube d'environ 100 millions
d'années-lumière on arrive
qualitativement à observer des premiers
agrégats de galaxies qui rappellent la
structure des amas
au fur et à mesure des recherches sur le
sujet bien sûr les ordinateurs sont
devenus de plus en plus puissants mais
les algorithmes aussi ont été améliorés
et ont permis de beaucoup gagner en
temps de calcul par exemple l'algorithme
dit de barnssaut étant n logarithme de N
au lieu d'être en N carré alors
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'avec disons un million de galaxies il
faudra quelques millions d'opérations au
lieu de 1000 milliards ça fait un gain
substantiel quand même au prix d'un
sacrifice limité dans la précision de la
simulation la figure que vous voyez ici
montre au cours du temps l'évolution de
la taille des simulations exprimée en
nombre de particules simulées alors
attention on emploie le terme de
particules pour désigner les masques
qu'on met dans la simulation on parle
pas de particules fondamentales du genre
des électrons ici ce qu'on appelle une
particule c'est une galaxie ou une masse
représentant un morceau de gaz ou de
galaxies
sur ce graphique attention en ordonner
l'échelle et logarithmiques donc ça
progresse de façon exponentielle on voit
qu'à chaque décennie la taille des
simulations accessibles a été multipliée
environ par 100 une des étapes
marquantes de cette évolution a
notamment été en 2005 la publication des
résultats de la simulation modestement
intitulée Millenium simulétion celle-ci
a été réalisée par un consortium
international d'astrophysiciens au moyen
d'un supercalculateur situé en Allemagne
et qui aura passé un mois complet sur
cette tâche ce calcul a simulé 10
milliards de particules chacune ayant
une masse d'environ 1 milliard de fois
celle du soleil ça veut dire que dans la
simulation une particule ne représente
pas une galaxie tout entière mais
seulement une toute petite fraction
environ 1/500e de galaxies
pour initialiser la simulation les
chercheurs ont utilisé une distribution
initiale homogène des particules avec
juste de toutes petites perturbations
dont les caractéristiques ont été
déduites des fluctuations du rayonnement
fossile on part des minuscules rides de
plus ou moins 0,1% dont on a parlé et
puisque l'attraction gravitationnelle va
amplifier les différences et bien on
s'attend à ce que ces petites
fluctuations soient en quelque sorte les
graines des grandes structures qui se
développeront au cours de la simulation
le volume couvert par la simulation
Millénium représente un cube de 2
milliards d'années-lumière de côté au
sein duquel on a pu observer la
formation progressive d'environ 20
millions de galaxies
et l'extrait que je vous ai passé au
tout début représente l'état de cet
univers virtuel à l'issue de la
simulation on peut y visualiser ces
structures filamentaires si
caractéristiques aux intersections
desquelles on trouve une concentration
importante de matière un représenter ici
en jaune
toutes ces structures ont des tailles
typiques de centaines de millions
d'années-lumière et elle semble
parfaitement raccord avec ce qu'on a pu
observer dans les catalogues de relevés
comme CFA2 d'EDF ou SDS
c'est en tout cas ce qui ressort de
cette image qui compare des tranches de
la simulation Millénium en rouge à des
représentations des galaxies des
différents relevés en bleu et violet
alors on ne retrouve pas exactement la
même image puisqu'il y a une part
d'aléatoire dans la simulation mais
comme vous pouvez le constater on a le
même genre de structure dont la taille
semble similaire
bon alors très bien mais dire que ça
ressemble ça n'est pas vraiment
suffisant on peut pas se contenter de
dire que visuellement ça semble coller
il nous faut des moyens de faire cette
comparaison avec des données chiffrées
alors voyons le genre d'analyse qu'on
peut faire pour faire une comparaison
quantitative entre d'un côté les
résultats des simulations et de l'autre
les structures qu'on retrouve dans les
observations on veut d'une certaine
manière mesurer le degré de regroupement
des galaxies à quel point elles sont
dispersées ou au contraire proches les
unes des autres
pour ça il existe un moyen ce qu'on
appelle la fonction de corrélation c'est
une courbe qui mesure en quelque sorte à
quel point on a des chances de trouver
une nouvelle galaxie quand on s'éloigne
d'une galaxie existante
si la galaxie étaient réparties
aléatoirement la fonction de corrélation
serait nulle quel que soit la distance
la chance de trouver une nouvelle
galaxie est la même
avec des galaxies qui présentent un
certain degré de regroupement la
fonction de corrélation va être
généralement décroissante on a beaucoup
de chance de trouver une galaxie proche
d'une galaxie existante ça traduit le
regroupement et cela va en diminuant
quand on s'éloigne
et la forme exacte de la courbe qu'on
obtient permet de caractériser plus
précisément la nature des structures que
l'on forme
ces courbes de fonctions de corrélation
on peut les calculer précisément à
partir des données réelles issues des
relevés de galaxies mais aussi en
utilisant les résultats des simulations
et on peut comparer les deux pour voir
si ça colle si bien que ça
la figure que vous voyez ici fait cette
comparaison avec en bleu les
corrélations pour les vraies galaxies et
en rouge les résultats de la simulation
Millénium et vous voyez que les deux
sont en excellente accord ce qui
confirme que les structures formées dans
la simulation Millénium sont très
représentatives de celles qu'on observe
vraiment dans l'univers
[Musique]
depuis la simulation Millenium qui date
quand même de 2005 plein de nouvelles
simulations ont vu le jour profitant de
la puissance toujours croissante des
ordinateurs l'une des plus récentes et
spectaculaires c'est la simulation
outchu qui veut dire univers en japonais
vous pouvez admirer ici un extrait du
déroulement de cette simulation elle
utilise au total 2000 milliards de
particules soit 200 fois plus que
Millénium dans un volume d’univers
correspondant à un cube de 10 milliards
d'années-lumière de côté
une fois la simulation HP voici un
extrait de ce qu'on obtient on retrouve
bien sûr les structures filamentaires
dont on a déjà parlé les zones de vide
et celles de fortes concentration de
matière
alors si ça vous intéresse vous pouvez
télécharger sur leur site les résultats
détaillés de cette simulation outshu
juste l'ensemble des données pèse deux
pétaoctets donc il vous faudra un bon
millier de disques durs pour tout
stocker alors évidemment on pourrait
encore rajouter plus de particules pour
multiplier la taille de l'univers simulé
mais on y gagnerait pas forcément grand
chose pour améliorer les simulations il
existe deux autres voix gagner en
résolution et modéliser plus de
phénomènes c'est par exemple ce que fait
la simulation illustrée TNG qui est en
quelque sorte la descendant de la
simulation Millenium quand je parle de
gagner en résolution ça veut dire
utiliser des particules représentant de
plus petites quantités de matière pour
avoir plus de finesse quitte à modéliser
des régions éventuellement plus petites
de l'espace
dans la simulation illustriste TNG 50 on
se concentre sur un petit cube de 50
millions d'années-lumière mais avec des
particules de seulement 50000 masse
solaires ce qui permet de suivre de
façon détaillée la façon dont se forment
les galaxies comme on le voit sur cette
extrait vidéo qui zoom sur un de ces
phénomènes
mais comme je l'ai dit une autre piste
d'amélioration consiste à modéliser plus
de phénomènes physiques les équations de
simulation que je vous ai décrites tout
à l'heure reste assez rudimentaire
puisqu'on ne traitait que l'interaction
gravitationnelle en fait ça revient à
traiter toute la matière comme si
c'était de la matière noire qui
n'interagit que par la gravité mais on
peut essayer de faire mieux que ça ainsi
dans les simulations du consortium
illustré TNG on trouve non seulement les
interactions gravitationnelles mais
également le comportement du gaz le
rayonnement les effets de magnétisme ou
d'hydrodynamique
cela leur a permis par exemple dans la
simulation illustrée TNG 300 d’estimer
les fonctions de corrélation de façon
indépendante pour les différentes formes
de matière les étoiles les trous noirs
le gaz la matière noire etc et on voit
qu'elles ont des répartitions légèrement
différentes alors pour comparer ces
simulations aux observations on ne peut
plus se concentrer uniquement sur les
relevés de galaxies parce qu'il nous
renseigne que sur la matière lumineuse
il nous faut aussi une idée de comment
se répartissent le gaz interstellaire ou
encore la matière noire heureusement il
existe d'autres méthodes d'observation
comme les effets de l'antigravitationnel
ou encore ce qu'on appelle les forêts
Liman alpha des quasars faudra que je
vous parle un jour des quasars et de ces
mystérieuses forêts en les combinant ces
différentes techniques associées au
catalogue des galaxies permettent de
faire une image assez précise de la
façon dont est distribué la matière dans
l'univers et notamment comment elle
varie aux différentes échelles
d'observation
en conclusion on voit que les
simulations et les observations
permettent de mieux comprendre la
structure de l'univers et comment
celle-ci a pu se former à partir de
minuscules fluctuations primordiales et
ça nous renseigne aussi au passage sur
les mécanismes à l'oeuvre lors des
premiers instants du Big Bang qui ont
donné naissance à ses fluctuations qui
sont en quelque sorte les ancêtres des
grandes structures de la toile cosmique
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui comme
toujours plus d'infos ci-dessous
notamment le billet de blog et puis
aussi le serveur discord n'hésitez pas à
le rejoindre pour continuer la
discussion le lien est en description
merci particulier à Maxime trebitch qui
est astrophysicien et qui a bien voulu
répondre à mes questions pour préparer
le script de cette vidéo et puis moi sur
ce je vous dis à très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos à bientôt